hi my name is Charlotte peel and I'm a
second year PhD student at Stanford
University
in this video my collaborator Lun jehu
and I will be presenting our joint work
on a new notion that we've termed
comparative learning
we'll be structuring the talk as follows
I'll first provide some motivation and
review the concepts of realizable and
agnostic learning before introducing the
definition of comparative learning as a
generalization of these two tasks
we'll then move on to considering the
sample complexity of comparative
learning where I'll walk through an
example to demonstrate why existing
methods used to analyze the sample
complexities of realizable and agnostic
learning cannot be easily applied to
comparative learning
building on this example I'll introduce
the mutual VC Dimension which is a
variant of the VC Dimension that we show
is able to characterize the sample
complexity of comparative learning as
the main result of this paper
I'll then hand things over to lunja who
will give a brief overview of the other
settings where we consider a comparative
variant of existing learning tasks
they'll also touch on the connection
between comparative learning and
multi-accuracy in multi-calibration
which we leverage to provide a sample
complexity characterization of
distribution-free realizable
multi-accuracy and multi-calibration
finally he'll come back to our main
result the sample complexity
characterization of comparative learning
that I mentioned earlier and provide
some details on the proof of this result
to introduce this notion we'll be
focusing on binary classification this
is a learning task where I assume I'm
given data points labeled with negative
1 and 1 that are drawn IID from some
unknown distribution mu
these data points are given to a
learning algorithm whose goal is to
Output a Model F that achieves good
accuracy against mu
here by good accuracy I mean that with
high probability the labels predicted by
F will match the true labels outputted
by mu
now in general this may be an impossible
task if I don't see a large portion of
the domain in my training set then I
have absolutely no information about
what the labels of these unseen points
should be
so we're going to need to make some sort
of a simplification to make this a
problem that we had a chance to tackle
one option could be to make some
assumptions about this unknown
distribution mu which might allow the
algorithm to make some conclusions about
unseen data points based on the points
it's already seen
another natural option could be to relax
our learning goal rather than requiring
that the outputted model achieved good
accuracy against mu maybe this could be
modified to be a more reasonable
expectation
and so these two approaches to modifying
the learning problem that I just
mentioned are captured by the realizable
and agnostic learning settings in
classic learning theory
realizable learning introduces an
assumption about the unknown
distribution mu in particular it
guarantees that the labels of mu will
match some hypothesis from a constrained
class of hypotheses h
the outputted model is then still
required to have good accuracy with
respect to the Target distribution
on the other hand agnostic learning
makes no assumptions about the data
distribution but again introduces a
constrained hypothesis class as a way to
modify the learning goal
rather than requiring that the outputted
model of good accuracy agnostic learning
only requires that the outputted model
has accuracy that is competitive with
the best performing hypothesis in this
constrained class
so a key commonality I want to highlight
here is that both of these learning
settings are defined by this constrained
hypothesis class H however this class is
playing a very different role in each
setting
and while this additional hypothesis
class is a standard feature of these
learning settings we end up having to
make a choice about whether we should
use this class for introducing
assumptions about the data or to relax
the learning goal
in our work we consider settings where
we want to make both of these
modifications rather than having just a
single hypothesis class we introduce one
class that controls assumptions about
the data distribution and another class
that relaxes the learning goal
this is the setting that we end up
calling comparative learning more
formally comparative learning takes the
data assumption from realizable learning
and assumes that the labels drawn from
mu match some hypothesis in a
constrained Source class s additionally
comparative learning mimics the model
requirement used in agnostic learning
and only requires that the accuracy of
the outputted model be competitive with
the best hypothesis in a benchmark Class
B
even though the source in Benchmark
classes could look very different from
each other we always compare the
outputted hypothesis to what could be
achieved using this Benchmark class and
this comparison is the source of the
name comparative learning
intuitively the way to think about
comparative learning is that it captures
a landscape of different learning tasks
each parameterized by a realizable
learning task that uses a source
hypothesis class s and an agnostic
learning task associated with a
benchmark hypothesis Class B
comparative learning is a more
expressive notion than realizable and
agnostic learning and more importantly
we find that it has many powerful
applications and leads us to a rich
collection of results including solving
an open problem about the sample
complexity of an existing learning task
before we get to those applications and
results it's important to understand a
basic question about comparative
learning namely what is its simple
complexity or how much data do we need
to achieve this comparative learning
goal and before I get into our results
on this question I want to quickly
review what is known about the sample
complexities of realizable and agnostic
learning because these are two very
related and well-studied problems
so the sample complexities of realizable
and agnostic learning are both
characterized by a notion of
expressiveness of their hypothesis class
called the VC dimension in more detail
the VC dimension of a hypothesis class
is the largest subset of points on which
every possible labeling can be captured
by some hypothesis in the class
when a subset has this property we say
that it is Shattered by the hypothesis
in the diagram on the right here H has a
VC dimension of two because it can
realize every possible labeling of X2
and X3 but cannot realize all the
labelings of any three points
so with this information in hand it
would be natural to assume that because
comparative learning is a combination of
realizable and agnostic learning tasks
there should be some way to combine
information about the sample
complexities of learning The Source in
Benchmark classes to make a conclusion
about the combined comparative learning
task
however it turns out that things are not
quite as simple as we might hope this is
because the source and Benchmark classes
can interact in unexpected ways to
result in outcomes that could not be
predicted by their individual VC
Dimensions alone
so let's look at a simple example to
illustrate how this can happen
in this example suppose that I have my
two hypothesis classes S and B and a
domain that has been partitioned into
two halves on one half of the domain all
the hypotheses in s are always just
constant well B shatters that half of
the domain and realizes all possible
labelings
on the other half this behavior is
Switched as shatters the domain while
all hypotheses in B are constant
assuming our domain has infinite size
then the BC dimensions of both S and B
are infinite because they each shatter
half of the domain this means that both
S and B are very difficult to learn and
require many samples in both the
agnostic and realizable settings
in contrast when we combine SMB into a
comparative learning problem the task
becomes trivial
so we know that we can exactly match the
data on the left half of the domain by
outputting a constant function and we
also know that we can exactly match the
performance of any hypothesis in B on
the right side of the domain by again
just outputting a constant function
this means that by outputting the all
constant function we've automatically
satisfied the requirements of the
comparative learning problem without
having to sample any data points so even
though both S and B independently were
very difficult to learn when combined
the resulting learning problem is very
easy which is not something we could
have predicted from just considering
these two problems individually
this example also highlights another way
in which comparative learning May
diverge from the standard realizable and
agnostic learning settings while
empirical risk minimization or the
algorithm that outputs the hypothesis
that minimizes the empirical risk over
the training data is known to perform
well on agnostic and realizable learning
problems and get close to the optimal
sample complexity upper bound it can
fail miserably when applied to
comparative learning
for instance we just saw that this for
this particular example no samples are
required to comparatively learn however
ERM may require an extremely large
sample in order to satisfy the
requirements of the comparative learning
task
if we suppose that the true labeling
matches the hypothesis on the left then
there exists a hypothesis in B that
achieves zero error the all-constant
hypothesis making our learning goal very
very strict
however running ERM on a small sample
could potentially output one of the two
hypotheses on the right neither of which
solve our comparative learning problem
so even though we know there is a way to
learn using no sample data ERM is going
to require a huge sample of data in
order to generalize well in this case
hopefully working through this example
has helped clarify this observation that
if we want to understand the sample
complexity of comparative learning it's
insufficient to consider the
complexities of these two hypothesis
classes individually
what we really care about is this
interaction between the two classes
specifically the amount of complexity
that they share
and in our paper we introduce a natural
extension of the BC Dimension intended
to capture this shared complexity
we've called this the mutual VC
dimension and so while the VC dimension
in the standard setting looks at the
size of the largest set Shattered by a
single hypothesis class the mutual VC
Dimension considers the collection of
subsets Shattered by a hypothesis class
S as well as the collection of subsets
Shattered by a second hypothesis Class B
and then Returns the size of the largest
subset that lies in the intersection of
these two collections
going back to our previous example the
entire left portion of the domain was
shattered by B while the right portion
was shattered by S however these two
regions were completely disjoint and so
there were actually no points Shattered
by both classes simultaneously
this means that for this example the
mutual VC dimension of the two classes
was Zero
this example supports a conjecture that
in the same way that the sample
complexities of realizable learning and
agnostic learning are characterized by
the BC Dimension the mutual VC Dimension
may be an appropriate characterization
of the sample complexity of comparative
learning
in our paper we show that this intuition
holds true
in particular our main result proves
that we can upper and lower bound the
sample complexity of comparative
learning using the mutual VC dimension
now that we've seen the definition of
comparative learning as well as our main
sample complexity result I'll hand
things over to lunja who will be giving
an overview of some related results and
extensions as well as some details on
the proof of the theorem we just saw
thank you Charlotte for presenting the
first half of the talk my name is Linda
I'm going to present the second half of
the talk
to summarize what Charlotte has already
talked about we introduce a new learning
task comparative learning as a
combination of realizable learning and
agnostic learning we show that the
sample complexity of comparative
learning can be characterized using the
mutual BC Dimension which is the new
complexity measure we Define for pairs
of hypothesis classes
later in this talk I will give you an
overview how we prove this result but
here I would like to emphasize that this
result is just one of the numerous
interesting results in this paper
you might think that comparative
learning sounds like a random thought
experiment but it ended up giving us
valuable insights and as we show in this
paper comparative learning has plenty of
powerful applications and Rich
extensions
the main application we show for
comparative learning in this paper is a
sample complexity characterization for
distribution free realizable
multi-accuracy and multi-calibration
this result solves an open problem in
our earlier paper with our advisor
omariongold I will talk more about this
result in the next few slides
more generally we can take any learning
task studied in the learning theory
literature and we can ask the question
of whether there is a comparative
variant for that learning task
for example for online learning people
have also studied a realizable setting
and an agnostic setting
a famous result is that in both settings
we can characterize the optimal regret
using the little Stone dimension
in this paper we study online learning
in our comparative setting and we show
that in this setting the optimal regret
can be characterized using a mutual
little Stone Dimension which is a
complexity measure we Define again for
pairs of hypothesis classes
another classic result in learning
theory is boosting and in this paper we
give an efficient algorithm that can
boost a weak comparative learner to a
strong comparative learner
we also study regression in the
comparative setting with real valued
hypothesis and general loss functions
we prove sample complexity results for
comparative regression in certain
settings
as you can see comparative learning
leads us to a rich collection of results
and if you read our paper there are
actually more results for example
independent of the machine learning
setup we prove an upper bound on a
notion of mutual covering number in
terms of our mutual obesity Dimension
this result can be viewed as a
generalization of a more classic result
all these results convey a very strong
message that comparative learning opens
up in almost an explored playground
which consists of learning tasks where
two or more hypothesis classes interact
in interesting ways
usually in learning theory a learning
task only involves a single hypothesis
class
but our results show that there are a
lot of interesting results to be
discovered in settings where there are
multiple hypothesis classes
in fact in the algorithmic fairness
literature people have already looked at
many learning tasks with multiple
hypothesis classes but to the best of
our knowledge there hasn't been a lot of
work that studied the interaction
between hypothesis classes or defined
complexity measures for pairs of
hypothesis classes except for this work
and our earlier work with Soma rheingold
so there's still a lot to explore in
this area
now I would like to talk more about our
multi accuracy and multi-calibration
result
in pack learning the goal is to minimize
the classification error defined as the
probability that the true label Y is
different from the predicted label f of
x
in practice however this classification
error is usually not our only
consideration
for example if we want to deploy a model
to make decisions about people then
fairness is another important
consideration
for two models with the same
classification error it could be the
case that one model is much better than
the other in terms of fairness
considerations
also classification error only counts
the number of mistakes our model is
making but it doesn't capture how many
but it doesn't capture which mistakes
our model is making
and in applications such as self-driving
cars it is important to avoid serious
mistakes when we cannot avoid all
mistakes
accuracy in multi-calibration can be
viewed as learning Frameworks that allow
us to capture these various goals that
appear in practice and in fact these
Notions allow us to customize our
learning goal
more specifically multi accuracy and
multi-calibration are in this General
framework of learning real valued
hypothesis here we focus on the
realizable settings so there is a source
hypothesis class and every Source
hypothesis in this class is a real
valued function that Maps individuals to
real numbers between -1 and 1.
we assume that our data is labeled
according to a source hypothesis and
what this means in this real valued
setting is that the conditional
expectation of the label y given the
individual X is equal to S of x
given data our learner outputs a Model F
which is also a real valued function
which Maps individuals to real numbers
between -1 and 1.
the goal is to achieve them either the
multi-accuracy guarantee or the
multi-calibration guarantee with
probability at least Y minus Delta
if you're not familiar with these
Notions these equations might look
complicated to you but what's important
here is that both multi-accuracy and
multi-calibration are defined with
respect to another hypothesis class the
distinguisher class here the
distinguisher class consists of
distinguishers which are again function
real valued functions mapping
individuals to real numbers between -1
and 1.
the power of multi accuracy and
multi-calibration is that they allow us
to customize our learning goal by
choosing the distinguisher class D
and this also makes multi accuracy in
multi-calibration become learning tasks
involving a pair of hypothesis classes
here we have the source hypothesis class
s and the distinguisher class D
in this paper we show that the sample
complexity of distribution free realized
about multi-accuracy and
multi-calibration is characterized by
the mutual fat shattering dimension of
the two hypothesis classes s and D
as we mentioned earlier this result
solves an open problem in our earlier
paper with Omar rangos and we proved
this result as an application of our
sample complexity characterization for
comparative learning
here I would like to verify that
even when theorem Y is given are proof
of theorem 2 is still non-trivial and it
requires a lot of work
now I would like to talk about how we
prove theorem 1. as we you will see our
proof is pretty short but it is very
interesting and cute proof and it makes
an insightful connection to learning
partial hypothesis
the task of learning partial hypothesis
has been started in several previous
papers and it has a realizable setting
and an agnostic setting here I will
focus on the agnostic setting due to
time constraint
as usual in the agnostic setting we make
no assumption on the data distribution
and how the goal is to Output the model
with the classification error are
propounded by the best classification
error achievable by a hypothesis in a
hypothesis class plus some small Epsilon
the only difference is that the compart
the hypothesis we consider here may be
partial in the sense that they map some
individuals to plus one minus one but
they can also map some in some
individuals to the undefined label which
is represented by the star here
for these partial hypothesis the
classification error is still defined as
the probability that the true label Y is
different from the predicted label h of
X and since H may be partial in the case
where H of X is star we always have y
being different from h of X this is
because the true label Y is always
either plus 1 or -1
and it never takes the value star
in this partial hypothesis learning
setting
in a previous paper by Alan Hanukkah
hoseman and Martin
the authors showed that the simple
complexity of reliably agnostically
learning partial hypothesis is
characterized by the VC dimension of the
partial hypothesis class
for a partial hypothesis crossed the VC
Dimension is defined as usual to be the
maximum size of a shattered subset and
here we only consider shattering using
plus ones and minus ones
our approach for proving our main result
theorem 1 is by reduction to this
previous result theorem 3. and
specifically for a comparative learning
task with the source class S and A
Benchmark Class B we want to construct a
partial hypothesis class H so that we
can relate the partial so that we can
relate the comparative learning task for
S and B to the task of learning the
partial hypothesis class h
the way we construct this partial
hypothesis class H is as follows we take
every pair of source hypothesis s and
Benchmark hypothesis B and we construct
an agreement hypothesis a sub s b
if SNP assigned the same label to an
individual then the agreement hypothesis
also assigns the same label to that
individual as S and P
if SNB assign different labels to an
individual then the agreement hypothesis
assigns the undefined label star to that
individual
we construct the partial hypothesis
class H so that it consists of all such
agreement hypothesis for every pair of S
and B
coming from the source class and The
Benchmark class with respectively
our construction of the partial
hypothesis cost H allows us to focus on
the complexity shared by the two classes
S and B and ignore the complexity that
is only present in one of the classes
using the partial hypothesis class H we
can prove these three lemmas which shows
that the VC dimension of the partial
hypothesis class H is equal to the
mutual BC dimension of the classes S and
B and we can relate the comparative
learning task for S and B to the task of
learning the partial hypothesis class h
using these lemmas we are able to prove
our main result theorem 1 using this
previous result theorem 3. and our proof
for theorem of 1 also works when S and B
themselves are partial hypothesis
classes
finally here is a list of takeaways
thank you for watching